If you want to hear the three hidden
reasons that Amanda Young defies
Jigsaw near the end of her story, then
stick around to the end of this video.
One of Jigsaw’s goals with his victims was
to convert those who passed his tests into
followers of his methods and one of his most
loyal followers was a woman named Amanda Young.
Welcome to Horror History, my name is
Professor CZsWorld and in today’s lesson
I’ll be analysing the life of the
third major Jigsaw disciple, Amanda.
Out of everyone to help out Jigsaw over
the years, Amanda probably has the most
troubled past, so let’s take it back to
her childhood to try to understand her.
While there is no canon explanation as
to why Amanda gets into a life of crime,
there is cut content from Saw III that suggests
she was abused by her father, who used to lock
her up in the dark for hours on end. It’s
unlikely any future film will further explore
Amanda’s past, so that seems like a reasonable
explanation. I mean, I can live with that.
Her first canon appearance comes in the 1990s. She
was addicted to heroin and would often
shoot up while listening to The Used.
That is their best album, so I guess not
all hope was lost on her, but others would not
agree. She eventually attended a recovery clinic
called Homeward Bound, but her issues were so bad
that her doctor, Jill Tuck, considered her to
be a lost cause and dropped her from treatment.
It was during her time at Homeward Bound
that she first got on John Kramer’s radar,
because he was married to Jill Tuck at the
time. It was also most likely where she met
another addict named Cecil Adams. One night, the
two planned to hold up the clinic after closing,
to steal some medication to relieve their
withdrawals. Even when Cecil had second
thoughts about committing the crime, Amada
convinced him to go back and carry it out,
and Cecil’s desperation eventually led to the
accidental miscarriage of Jill Tuck’s baby.
As far as we know, Jigsaw never knew Amanda
was involved with the incident, but police did.
I’m guessing it has something to do with security
cameras at the clinic. Although she wasn’t
technically guilty of anything in this instance,
one of the cops, Detective Eric Matthews saw to
it that she was punished by faking the evidence
needed to get her convicted of drug possession.
“You sent me to prison. I was
guilty of a lot of things,
but not the drug charge you framed me for.”
She was eventually released, but did not realize
that the worst of her punishment was only just
beginning. One day in May of 2004 she woke up
with the taste of blood and metal in her mouth.
A contraption is bolted to her head, and videotape
starts playing and explains that it will open and
rip her jaws apart if she’s unable to obtain
the key in 60 seconds. The key is located in
the stomach of her cellmate, and she has to
do the unthinkable in order to obtain it.
She gets the key just in time, and she was
congratulated by the puppet from the tape.
“Congratulations. You are still alive.
Most people are so ungrateful to be
alive. But not you. Not anymore.”
After escaping the building, she
goes straight to the police to
report what happened to her, and
tells them that she is grateful,
and that Jigsaw had helped her. When
she returned home after everything,
John Kramer is sitting in her apartment, and
he tells her that her life has just begun.
That’s when she starts training with Jigsaw for
the next five months. One behaviour commonly
seen in recovering addicts is feeding
their withdrawals with something else,
and due to the fact that Amanda was coming
out of a chemical dependency on drugs,
her brain had to find something else to latch
onto. This may explain why her loyalty to John,
who was helping her overcome her problems by
teaching her his moral code, was so fierce.
She assisted him in putting together one of his
most complex games to date, which would take
place in October of 2004. She uses a pig mask to
disguise herself, a symbol that is perfect for her
because the Year of the Pig in the Chinese zodiac
stands for rebirth, and Jigsaw believes she has
been reborn as a better person.
JIGSAW: “The marks on your arms.
They’re from another life.
You’ll leave that life behind.”
Jigsaw makes her promise her allegiance
before handing her an envelope containing a
file on a photographer named Adam Stanheight. She
sneaks into Adam’s apartment and knocks him out
using an injection. Then, she’s able to transport
his body to the site of the game using a dolly.
Somehow, nobody sees this or finds it suspicious
in any way, and Amanda shackles his leg to the
pipe, puts him in the bathtub and leaves the key
sitting on his chest. This was one of her first
mistakes as John’s apprentice. Amanda was supposed
to place the key in a place where Adam had a
chance to get it before it washed down the drain.
This would have made Adam’s game more winnable,
but Amanda had a nasty habit of rigging
things against the participant of each game.
I believe she does this because has become
so dependent on Jigsaw’s care for her,
that she doesn’t like the idea of anyone
else surviving and becoming his disciple. She
essentially wants to be the only one, so that she
can have all of John’s attention. We call this,
Jealous Girlfriend Syndrome. Rule number 1: NEVER
try to reason with someone who has this condition.
After Jigsaw places himself at the
center of the game for surveillance,
Amanda puts on the final touches by turning
off the lights and closing the door.
Adam would end up losing the game, and his
punishment was to spend his remaining days in the
bathroom, but the winner of the game, Dr. Gordon,
had promised to go back to save Adam, so Amanda,
not wanting there to be another survivor, sneaks
back into the bathroom to finish off Adam.
Jigsaw would eventually discover her
transgression, but before he did,
he believed that she was fully rehabilitated
by surviving the reverse bear trap,
and brought her into Jill’s practice
as evidence that his methods can turn
a person’s life around in ways that
Jill’s medical treatments could not.
Amanda was proud to have recovered from her
addiction even after Jill had given up on her.
“It works. It’s real. He helped me.”
However, at some point over the next year,
possibly due to the trauma of what she had
done to Adam, she began self-harming. Also
during this time she helps Jigsaw develop a
new game with two major contributions.
First, she put together a test for the
man who had wrongfully imprisoned her, Eric
Matthews, in order to see if he could test
his restraint and solve the Jigsaw case
without resorting to dirty police work.
Then, she was asked to take part
in the next game in October 2005,
which involved a group of ex-convicts who had
all been set up by Matthews, but were also all
guilty of other crimes. She would essentially play
the role that John had played in the first game,
by secretly placing herself in the center of
it so that she could ensure that all the rules
are followed. If only she were still around, we
could give her a job with the Houston Astros.
The game challenged it’s participants to find
the antidotes hidden around the house as a
deadly nerve gas seeped into their systems. It
is likely that Amanda had already been treated
with the antidote before ever going into the
game, because she had already passed her test,
and would need to stay healthy in
order to facilitate the game. However,
it was possible she was partially being
tested again, because she had once more
demonstrated her inability to cherish
life when she started cutting herself.
I personally think she was given an
antidote, because she doesn’t show
the same symptoms of the nerve gas as
the others, but Jigsaw was still making
her repent for her self-harm just by putting
her in a dangerous situation with a bunch of
ex-convicts. She also doesn’t seem to know
all the secrets of the house, for example,
she is surprised to find that the trap
door under the safe is locked later on.
But despite her theoretically being in less
danger than the others, Amanda would endure
more suffering than ever before when the Nerve
Gas House game didn’t quite go according to plan…
When the Nerve Gas House game begins, Amanda
acts as if she's in a panic to help sell the
idea that she's a participant. Yeah, Amanda
is a pretty decent actress, unlike Adam.
*Adam pretending to choke (poorly)*
Amanda uncovers the tape with the instructions
for the game and explains her past
experience being in a Jigsaw trap.
"He's testing us. He wants us to survive this."
The first death occurs when a man named Gus
ignores Jigsaw's advice not to use a key
on the door. The others escape the room
and begin searching the house
and Amanda turns on the lights.
The next death occurs when a man named
Obi fails to retrieve the antidotes from
his trap inside of the furnace. When one
of the participants, a boy named Daniel,
asks why Amanda was chosen for the game, she
tells him that it was because she was a junkie,
which is a clue about one of the things they
are supposed to be figuring out: which is that
each of them were framed by the kid's father:
Eric Matthews. She also explains that she was
included in this second game because she took
up self-harm as an unhealthy coping mechanism.
They find the next trap, which is
intended for Xavier, a drug dealer.
His test is to metaphorically crawl
through the same pit that the junkies
he dealt to did, by finding the key to
the antidote in a huge pile of needles.
However, Xavier abuses his position as
the biggest guy in the room and forces
Amanda to do his test for him. He
tosses her into the needle pit,
which is one of the most horrifying twists that
could have possibly gone down for her character.
Amanda had already been through so much suffering
in order to overcome her addiction, and now she
was being thrown back into it, literally thrown
back into a world of needles and desperation.
There's also the risk for Amanda to go through
a relapse, which is when a drug user or someone
suffering from an addiction slips up once and
returns to the negative behaviours because of it.
And that can be a very dangerous thing, because
after being off of the heroin for a while,
her tolerance is likely to change
and put her at risk for an overdose.
We don't know what was in the syringes
in the needle pit, but for those reasons,
and the fact that many people are already
afraid of needles, this is widely regarded
as the most uncomfortable trap
in the entire Saw franchise.
At least it wasn't a pit filled
with various LEGO pieces though.
COMMERCIAL: "A man-da has fallen into the river, in LEGO City!"
This was absolutely traumatizing for Amanda,
and this is just speculation, but I'd point to
this as the reason she becomes so unforgiving
towards victims of the traps from here on out.
She finds the key with 7 seconds to go, but that's
not enough time for Xavier to unlock the door with
the antidote. I think the fact still remains that
he was nearly able to escape without suffering or
rehabilitating at all, and this stuck with Amanda
for the rest of her time working for Jigsaw.
Soon after, the group splits up
to continue searching for the
antidotes and the clue about Daniel's
link to Eric Matthews is discovered.
“What are you doing with
him? This is your father?”
So the question that I have here is: did
Amanda know that Daniel was Eric’s son?
We’ve already seen that she has the ability
to act, when she pretends to be surprised
that she is back inside of Jigsaw’s game,
but was she acting when she said this line?
“Tell me that’s not your father.”
I think she is, and here’s why. First: the fact
that she created the test for Eric Matthews.
“Hello Eric.”
She likely would have known a lot about him
in order to do this, and at the very least,
read his profile and known
his most basic family info.
I also think her reaction when Daniel almost
voluntarily reveals who his father is early on,
tells us that Amanda knew all
along. Let’s roll that clip.
DANIEL: "I mean, I've been in trouble a few times, you know? In and out of stuff.
My Dad’s a… he’s um… he’s a real hard
ass. He’s probably got half the city
right now looking for me just so he can
kick my ass for disappearing on him.”
AMANDA: “Yeah. Probably.”
She seems kind of panicked when he’s about to
out himself, and then relieved when he doesn’t.
We don’t get to see much of her reaction when the
truth is revealed though, because moments later,
one of the other contestants chokes on the nerve
gas and passes away in Amanda’s arms. There’s no
time to mourn however, because Xavier can be heard
calling after her in the distance. She surveys
the house and discovers that he’s already taken
care of Jonas and will likely be after her life
next. She grabs Daniel and takes him to the first
room where they barricade themselves for safety.
Together, they’re able to move the safe and
uncover a trap door leading down to the basement
just before Xavier knocks the door down. The
basement is a series of tunnels and rooms,
one of which is the bathroom where
she had brought Adam one year earlier.
She leads Daniel there, with Xavier close behind.
The two devise a plan that has been used time
and time again in the Saw series, pretending to
be dead, which is ultimately how Daniel gains the
upper hand on Xavier. Once again, Amanda’s acting
skills shine right here, probably one of the under
appreciated strengths of her character. With them
being the only two survivors, she gets Daniel
the antidote out of the safe and saves his life.
He’s still very weak, and when the doors
open after the three hours has expired,
she takes him to Jigsaw, where he’s given
an oxygen mask and safely stowed in another
safe in Jigsaw’s workshop. But before
this game was over, Amanda had one more
job that would put her face to face with
the man who wronged her so many years ago.
Amanda later returned to the Nerve Gas house,
once again disguised in robes and pig mask in
order to carry out the final part of the test for
Eric Matthews in case he failed his test. He would
fail by using police brutality to force John
to take him to the location of the game. Amanda
waited for him in the bathroom, and injected
him with the anesthetic before he could react.
She shackled him to the pipe where she had once
shackled Adam and leaves behind a tape, which
explains that this was her training, and she would
eventually be the one to carry on John's work.
She leaves him in the bathroom echoing
Jigsaw's signature phrase "Game Over",
thinking he'll probably die there, but to her
surprise, she finds that he's able to escape by
crushing his foot and sliding out the shackle.
She hides when she realizes he's on the loose,
but he manages to catch her
before she leaves the house.
The two get into a skirmish in which
she immobilizes him even further by
attacking his weak ankle. At first
she's willing to leave it at that,
but when she hears what he yells out
after her, she stops in her tracks.
"You're not Jigsaw! You hear me? You're nothing!"
Remember, Amanda had nothing after coming out
of her life as an addict and latched onto John,
so her training to become
Jigsaw meant everything to her.
Hearing those words, "you're not Jigsaw", hurt
her more than anything else possibly could have.
She literally falls to her knees at this remark,
and that's when she decides that she will not let
Eric Matthews live and goes back to finish him
off. She’s also starting to believe that not
everyone who survives a trap experiences the
same rehabilitation that she did, and I think
she realizes that Matthews hasn’t changed after
making it out of his shackle in the bathroom.
The movies don't actually show what she did
to him, but we can assume it's pretty bad,
because Amanda actually believes that
Matthews is dead for the next 6 months.
During this time, she continues
her apprenticeship with Jigsaw,
but he begins to fear that she's not fit for
the job after seeing her emotions get the
better of her a couple times now, first
against Adam and now against Matthews.
Jigsaw devises a new test for Amanda,
to test her self control and see if she's
really capable of bearing the Jigsaw name,
or if Matthews was right, and Amanda Young was
not destined to take over the role of Jigsaw.
Amanda is asked to help prepare for this
game, because she doesn't know she's being
tested along with the other participants.
I'm sure all of us can relate to finding
out about a test on the day of. Not
a good feeling. Not a good feeling.
Also helping to put together the next game
is another Jigsaw disciple, Mark Hoffman.
Amanda and Hoffman develop a rivalry, they
both want to be the one to take over John's
work after his passing, but neither wants
to share that honor with the other person.
She also develops an even closer bond with
John, who is getting physically weaker by
the day because of his cancer and requires Amanda
to push him around in a wheelchair and basically
be his personal caretaker. She begins living in
a small room at the Gideon Meat Packing Plant,
which would be Jigsaw’s new base
of operations from here on out.
She would also take on the responsibility
of setting up John's games, since he was
no longer able to do much physically. However,
Amanda, still shaken by what she had endured
at the Nerve Gas House, was not in the
mindset of giving people a second chance,
which is the whole point of Jigsaw's games,
to give people the chance to rehabilitate.
She instead started to see them
as vigilante acts of punishment,
and made her contraptions into
unwinnable death traps rather than games.
Her first victim was a man named Troy, who was
a fellow patient of Homeward Bound Clinic. He
was placed in a classroom, and yes, you
can see I took some inspiration for my
decorations here in the Horror History
classroom, I should've spent less time
praising Amanda for her ability to act and given
more compliments on her interior design skills.
But yeah, she put these chains
into Troy's flesh and made him
yank them out of his body in order
to escape. There was also a timer,
and this nailbomb would go off and kill him
if he was still in the room when it expired.
Only problem was that the door was welded shut,
so Troy never even had the chance
regardless of the outcome of the game.
There was also a game for one of the police
detectives, a woman named Alison Kerry. She
was tasked with reaching into a beaker of
acid to retrieve the key to her trap, but
Amanda had rigged this game as well, putting in
the wrong key, resulting in the death of Alison.
In her spare time, Amanda practices her mechanical
engineering skills and builds a collar device that
would be used in the next game. But at some
point, the pressure of her training to become
the next Jigsaw successor and the guilt about
all of the horrible things she had done to her
victims caused her to have a relapse. Not a
drug relapse, but self-mutilation relapse.
After promising Jigsaw to leave that behaviour
in her past life, she knew she had to keep it a
secret, and did so by cutting her inner thighs
and wearing jeans every day to cover it up.
One day in April of 2006, during one of the
final preparation days for this next game,
Amanda gets into a little quarrel with Hoffman.
She mockingly asks him when his test will be, and
he tells her he doesn’t need to be tested, because
he did not take his life for granted as she did.
Amanda boasts that he might
as well get used to her,
because she’s not going anywhere,
but Hoffman doesn’t seem so sure.
“You sure about that?”
John tells Amanda that it’s time to
get Dr. Lynn Denlon from the hospital,
which means the next game is about to begin.
Amanda shows up to Angel of Mercy Hospital and
waits until Dr. Denlon is alone in the changing
room. She locks her in, then attacks her and
uses a wheelchair to transport her back to
the building where John is being kept. When
Lynn wakes up, Amanda brings her into the room
with John, who explains the rules of the game.
Dr. Denlon’s collar is linked to John’s heart
rate monitor, so if he dies, or she moves out
of range by leaving the building, the collar
will explode and kill her. Her goal was to
keep John alive until Lynn’s husband, Jeff
Denlon, finished his trial in another area,
but Amanda and Lynn did not know that
Jeff was the other person being tested.
By doing this, John was also able to test Amanda.
John was aware that Amanda had rigged many of
her tests into execution devices, so he was
testing her ability to let Lynn Denlon’s test
go uninterrupted. If Amanda were to interfere
and do something that resulted in Lynn’s death,
then Jeff would likely come through and
get revenge on Amanda. So this was just
as much Amanda’s game as it was Lynn’s
or Jeff’s. She had to learn to control
her emotions and let the game play out, but
Dr. Denlon would not make that easy for her.
Hoffman delivers Jeff to
the beginning of his game,
and Amanda would keep tabs via computer monitors
and periodically update John on his progress.
After examining him, Dr. Denlon’s suggestion
is that they take John to a hospital because
his brain was herniating. This
suggestion quickly angers Amanda,
she’s already letting her emotional nature get
the better of her. She tells Lynn that a hospital
is pretty much out of the question. Amanda
is so ill-mannered and physically threatening
when speaking to Lynn, that the dying John
Kramer actually feels the need to intervene.
“Amanda! The doctor can’t do
what’s being asked of her if
you’re threatening her. The rules of
our game have been made very clear.”
Each game has a rule-keeper. It’s John in the
bathroom game, Amanda in the Nerve Gas House
and John again here in the Death Collar Game,
but that would go out the window when John goes
into some kind of life-threatening seizure episode
that would force Lynn and Amanda to work together.
John loses control of his body
and thrashes around violently,
to the point that Dr. Denlon is unable
to restrain him enough to help him.
She calls for Amanda to help hold him down and
administer oxygen. Eventually, he stabilizes,
but the scare hits Amanda hard, and she has
to leave the room with tears in her eyes.
We’ve already established that Amanda’s emotions
are her weakness, and I think seeing her idol,
Jigsaw, she man she views as her
saviour, in such vulnerable state
brought down her psyche even further,
and all of the experiences she would go
through that day would push her closer
and closer to the edge of a breakdown.
Even after that though, Amanda still insists they
must perform the operation at the meatpacking
plant, rather than moving to a hospital
and… you know… getting them all arrested.
Lynn reluctantly agrees and gives Amanda
a list of materials needed which includes
an anaesthetic and a power drill. I can only
imagine how awkward it was at the checkout line.
When she gets back from getting the supplies,
she discovers Lynn taking a peak at the traps
and weapons stored in the area outside the
operating room and mockingly challenges her
to try to do her best Jack Torrance
on her, explaining that if she does,
John could easily rip off the heart rate monitor
and turn Dr. Denlon into Dr. Pile of Ashes.
Lynn is still not confident that these makeshift
tools will get the job done, and Amanda tells her,
“You’d be surprised what tools could save a life.”
...which is one of Amanda's most intelligent lines
because of its double meaning. She's giving Lynn
the tools she'll need to help John, but also
talking about how the tools in front of them,
the traps, helped to save her life by making
her appreciate life again and get off of drugs.
Before the surgery, Amanda checks back
in on Jeff's progress and updates John
on his whereabouts. He had just
made it through the first room,
and Amanda would soon face the first
obstacle in her portion of the game as well.
He asks her to retrieve an envelope with her
name on it in his desk drawer in the other room.
Since John had about as much energy as a horror
YouTuber the day after Halloween at this point, he
had Hoffman place the letter there. We never find
out what the original letter was supposed to say
though, because Hoffman pulls the old switcheroo
and leaves his own letter in the envelope.
Before going to retrieve it, the brain surgery
takes place and Amanda fills the role of Lynn’s
medical assistant, during which she’s unable to
cope with the seriousness of the situation and has
to look away for most of it. At the end of the
operation, John slipped into a critical state,
causing his heart rate to plummet and his brain to
fire off a random memory of him and his then-wife.
When his heart rate stabilized, he was
still in the hallucination of his wife
causing him to touch Lynn’s
elbow and say, “I love you.”
And that caused Amanda to do this.
🎵 Intense Horror Music 🎵
Amanda storms off to her bed, but
instead of playing with her creepy doll,
she opens up a secret box full of sharp objects.
Ohhhh, maybe that’s why she got into The Used.
“Found a box of sharp objects,
what a beautiful THING!!”
She cuts herself again to distract
herself from the emotional pain
she was going through and bandages up the
wounds to keep them a secret from Jigsaw.
When she comes back into the room
she’s in full jealous girlfriend mode,
and despite the 15 year age difference, she starts
weirdly kissing his neck…? I don’t speak woman,
but my guess is that his was her way
of telling Lynn, “back off b****!”
Lynn tells Amanda that he can’t hear her, so
Amanda freaks out and pulls a gun on Lynn.
It turns out that Jigsaw is actually
awake, and he tells off Amanda and
asks to be left alone with Lynn, which
was probably another phase of the test.
John knew that this would make Amanda
jealous, but he needed to push her to her
limit in order to determine if she’d really be
capable of handling her emotions going forward.
To further this, the next time Amanda comes
into the room, Jigsaw tells her they’re fine,
they don’t need her, which sends her
into an even darker rage. But John knew
that in order for Amanda to take over for
him, she would have to be self-motivated,
and that means not just acting out
of her love for John. In other words,
she had to become less emotionally dependent
on him, and the only way to do that is to let
go of that connection that was established
when he saved her from her life of drugs. If
she could contain her jealousy, John would
be convinced that she’d passed the test.
But he wasn’t counting on what would happen
next: Amanda went to go find the envelope
from John that Hoffman had interfered
with. She reads the note, which says:
“Amanda - You were with Cecil the night Jill
lost Gideon. You killed their child. You know
it and I know it, so do exactly as I say. Kill
Lynn Denlon or I will tell John what you did.”
Hoffman knew about this mistake that Amanda had
made back in the 90s, but he also knew how Amanda
felt about John. She would be heartbroken if John
found out that she was involved in the death of
his child, so she has to seriously consider
caving into Hoffman’s demand and killing Lynn
Denlon. She already disliked Dr. Denlon because
of her perceived relationship with John, but this
note from Hoffman motivated her even further, and
might just be enough to push her over the edge.
However, Amanda Young would not go down
without a fight, and she would find a
clever way to get back at Hoffman, before the
grand culmination of the Death Collar Game.
After being blackmailed by Detective Hoffman,
Amanda secretly made a very important move to
get revenge on him. In a flurry of emotions, she
goes to the cell where Jeff and Lynn’s daughter,
Corbett Denlon is being kept. Corbett has been
placed there by Hoffman, on John’s orders,
as an extra incentive for Jeff to make the
right choice after escaping from his game.
Remember, Amanda doesn’t know
that Jeff and Lynn are married,
so she probably doesn’t realize that Corbett
is Lynn’s daughter. She’s probably just knows
Corbett as Jeff’s daughter. But she
does know that Hoffman may very well
be the sole survivor by the end of the
day, and tells Corbett the following:
“Don’t trust the one who saves you.”
Just remember that, because I’ll come back to
it shortly. Not long after, Jeff completes his
final test, and he’s basically about to be on
his way to the operation room. Since Lynn was
able to keep John alive for all of it, he says
she is free to go, but Amanda has other ideas.
She decided that her best move given the
circumstances is to give in to Hoffman’s
demands and take out Lynn, and after doing
so. John commands her to unlock Lynn’s collar
and let her go, but she defies him. Her
emotional state has spiraled into such a
frenzy that I think Amanda actually starts
to believe that she knows better than John.
I imagine that her line of logic is that
John would be more hurt by discovering
that Amanda was involved in Gideon’s death
than he would be by Amanda disobeying him.
She also really doesn’t like Lynn,
so this is the easy choice to make.
John tries to convince her that
her own life is in Lynn’s hands,
but that just ends up upsetting Amanda
even more. Remember, rule number 1 of
Jealous Girlfriend Syndrome is to
NEVER try to reason with the person.
John brings up the victims he left
alive that Amanda tried to kill,
like Adam and Detective Matthews, but Amanda
claims that those people deserved to die,
and what she did was not different than
what Jigsaw does. She believes that Dr.
Denlon should not go free because she had not
rehabilitated, and through her eyes, nobody had.
There are obviously two factors at play here,
Amanda’s beliefs and Hoffman’s blackmail. I do
think that Amanda genuinely has doubts that
John’s methods work. As I mentioned earlier,
she had experienced first hand how
someone like Xavier could get through
his test without rehabilitating, and she
sees it again when Detective Matthews
makes a huge sacrifice to escape from the
bathroom, but still tries to get revenge
on Amanda and doesn’t seem to have changed.
Not to mention the fact that she eventually
relapsed and started cutting herself
again, even under Jigsaw’s training.
Hoffman’s letter was really
just kind of an extra incentive.
So Amanda shoots Lynn, and shortly after, Jeff
comes and sees that his wife has been killed,
and shoots Amanda. In her final
moments, John reaches out to her
and explains that this was her test.
When John had said he was testing,
“your will to live and keep someone alive,”
he was talking to Amanda, not Lynn.
He knew that she was making her games unwinnable,
but since his remaining days were very limited,
he decided to give her one last chance
out of desperation and she had failed
him. So Amanda passes away, a victim of
her own actions, on April 28th, 2006.
Despite the fact that she had failed her
test, and would be unable to take over
for John after his passing, she was still able
to help him in one small way after his death.
John would only survive a couple minutes longer
than Amanda, and that left Mark Hoffman as the
man who would take over Jigsaw’s legacy and
carry out the rest of his requests. However,
like Amanda, he too was corrupt, and strayed
from the original teachings of John Kramer.
However, as one of the last men
standing, he had too much power,
and was nearly unstoppable
within a matter of weeks.
Amanda actually may have played
a key role in helping to stop
him though. By telling Corbett Denlon
not to trust the man who rescues her,
she was able to get the message
out about Hoffman indirectly.
This is never confirmed in the movies,
but we can assume that after Hoffman
rescued Corbett after the conclusion of
the events at the meat packing plant,
that Corbett went on to tell the FBI that
someone warned her not to trust her rescuer.
So this could be the reason that the FBI refuses
to stop investigating him even after his name is
cleared, the reason that he eventually
gets caught and has to go on the run,
which EVENTUALLY leads to his downfall. None of
it may have happened if not for Amanda Young.
I’m still not going to call
her a hero or anything,
but throughout most of her story there
are multiple factors at play in her head,
so hopefully this video helped you understand her
mindset and some of the choices that she made.
If you want to hear more about how her
story connected with that of Hoffman or
other Saw characters, then click that video
on the left for some additional episodes of
Horror History and let me know who you’d
like to see me cover in the next lesson.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring that deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.